it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you get your hands on
Bayonetta 2 one of the very few games to
receive the coveted score of 10 out of
10 on
gamespot.com hailed by Mark Walton as a
masterclass in pure unadulterated action
game design where its insane eye popping
visuals M effortlessly with some of the
sharpest most joyful combat to ever
grace a video game this might be the
time you're going to have to go get a
Wii U if you don't have one you have
until Friday to think it over set your
clock to which time October
24th but if you're more of a turn-based
strategy played on a hexagonal based
grid type gamer you're in luck because
Sid Meers civilization beyond Earth is
launching globally all on the same day
players make choices at the beginning of
the game like what organization back
their expedition The Vessel they use
reach the planet and who are what
they're bringing to the world and that
affects what happens later the game
intentionally does not allow for
technology trading between civilizations
so it's impossible to unlock all the
games Technologies in a single
playthrough some of the Technologies are
exclusive to each Affinity so you're
going to be pouring a lot of hours in
this when it hits shelves this Friday we
were
chosen but let's go back to the badass
ladies kick and butt because the legend
of Kora is here to bend the elements of
water Earth Fire and Air air bending
mode makes her move faster and perform
various long and closed range moves
water bending emphasizes long range
attacks Earth bending is slow but
powerful and fire bending emphasizes
speed and close- range moves players can
swap between elements at any time and
combine them for additional power become
the last no wait one of many Airbenders
on the 22nd all right let's do this just
dance is back this week with an
impressive song list that includes hits
from Run DMC and Bonnie Tyler sadly it
only has the original version of Happy
by farel instead of the Weird Al version
which I think we can all agree is the
only version you should ever listen to
it also has that Tetris song get your
groove on on the
21st there's more music based games this
week with Fantasia music evolved for
Xbox the motion controlled music rhythm
game has you waving your hands as if you
were holding a wand to create the
Bohemian rap city there are other songs
but no one cares make sweet sweet music
October
21st also this week we get to visit
Stark in Arcadia with dreamfall chapters
an episodic story-driven Adventure game
set in parallel worlds of Science and
Magic zo's trapped in story time but
we'll learn to control her dreams and
Venture forth the first chapter is
dropping on the
21st and Bayonetta is not the only Wii U
release this week if you never got
around to playing Stealth Bastard you
can start with stealth Inc to a way
better looking sequel that gets to the
good stuff like killing a bunch of
clones way faster there's a lot of trial
and error in this game and it's all at
the expense of so so many clones and
it's super fun the mass murder begins
October 23rd for further details visit
gamespot.com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next
week